Okay, so I want to pick up in February the 19th, 1913, and this is volume 11 over there.
So the heading says that the divine will is opium that puts to sleep what is human in
the soul.
And one of the things that fascinates me about these writings is that when a thing has been
discovered or has just come into public use, Jesus will use the image.
And here is using the image of opium, which really hit the scene early in the 20th century.
So Louisa said, "Continue in my usual state, and having received Holy Communion, my always
loveable Jesus told me, 'My daughter, my will is like opium to the body.'"
Now what does opium do?
Now it's presumed you're not misusing opium.
So if you're using it correctly, it will produce sleep.
It'll be almost like an anesthetic, okay, it'll produce sleep.
So he says, "My will is like opium to the body.
That means human nature.
That human nature has to give way, and the divine will actually take over, and the divine
order actually take over."
The poor patients who have to undergo an operation, the severing of a leg or a neuron, are put
to sleep with the opium.
So there's a large dose of the opium given as an anesthetic, okay.
They stopped using opium when they realized the terrible mental effects that it can have
on people when it's given in large doses.
With it, they will not feel the sharpness of the pain, and after they wake up, they will
find themselves with the results of the accomplished operation.
If they have not suffered too much, it's all due to the opium, okay.
Now such is my will.
Now this is the example he's giving of his will.
My will is the opium of the soul, which puts to sleep the intelligence, the love of self,
and self-esteem, all that is human.
Now notice what needs to be put to sleep, the love of self, and self-esteem.
Now notice it doesn't really die.
And the intelligence, we would say rationalism, rationalism has become a scourge in the church
that you won't accept anything beyond what your puny intelligence understands.
The opium of my will does not allow displeasure, slander, suffering, or a state of interior
pains in the soul to penetrate deeply into her.
Now notice the word deeply.
It doesn't mean you are inhuman anymore, and you are immune to suffering, but the suffering
or the problem or the trials is not going to get you down.
Is that okay?
Because it keeps her as though as sleep, you know, beside that I want to give you Sam 131.
Sam 131 says my soul is like a weaned child on its mother's lap, and now a weaned child
on its mother's lap is completely peaceful and sleeps its head off.
But with this the soul still finds herself with the same effects and the same merits.
In other words, what she's doing in the divine will still has the same effects and the same
merits even more, oh how much she surpasses them.
Just as if she had thoroughly felt the suffering, but there's this difference.
The opium for the body has to be purchased and cannot be used often.
Notice this, or every day.
The reason is that it's a very dangerous substance, okay?
And it will give rise to hallucinations and all kinds of issues all the time.
And if a person wanted to overuse it, they would become dazed, especially if they had
a weak constitution.
On the other hand, the opium of my will, I give it out for free.
It can be taken at any moment, and the more often the soul takes it, the more light of
reason she acquires.
Now people who misunderstand the bit about the intelligence in line two need to connect
the fact that your reason grows.
God is not unreasonable, God is the source of our reason, okay?
And we know that the more a person grows in union with God, the more their intelligence
actually grows.
And if she is weak, she acquires divine strength, okay?
So the strength that we need is divine strength.
The health that we need is divine health.
The life that we need is divine life.
So after this, I seem to see people around me, she said, and I said to Jesus, who are
they?
And Jesus said, "They are the ones whom I entrusted to you some time ago.
I commend them to you, watch over them, I want to form this bond of union between
you and them, so as to have them always around me."
Now, one of the things we have to realize is that nobody goes to heaven alone.
And you don't go to hell alone either.
All of us bring people we have influenced to heaven with us or to hell with us, okay?
In the second half of the book of Revelation, there is a great image given to us, and it's
the image of woman.
And as the woman clothed with the sun, she takes everybody to heaven, and the opposite
of that is the terrible harlot that takes everybody to hell.
And those two images, you either take everybody with you to heaven or hell.
And so there are a number of people whom the Lord has assigned to each one of us.
He doesn't tell us who they are, okay?
But if you go to radiantlight.org to Elizabeth Wang's wonderful pictures on Christianity,
radiantlight.org, radiantlight, L-I-G-H-T, radiantlight.org, one of her wonderful pictures
of a person in a spiritual life, she shows a man wearing a kind of a priestly cape and
it's a long train on the back of it.
And on the train, there are hundreds of people.
So this person can find it difficult to go forward because you're bringing all these
people behind you.
And so one of the reasons why we have difficulties in certain things, like for example, supposing
I had great difficulty in forgiving someone, it's because that's the problem of some of
the people behind me.
And so I have to do the struggling and the praying and the repenting and all the rest
of it until we get victory and then they all get the grace to forgive the whole earth.
If I find it extremely difficult to be patient in a particular area, some of the folks leaning
on me have that problem.
I have to conquer it because I'm the one asked to take these people with me.
It's the mystery of our walk with God.
You don't go alone, okay.
And when we go into the higher volumes, Louisa will be told that everybody who tries to
live in the divine will is on her carpet, if I can put it down her trail, she said carry
us all, the whole lot of us, every single one.
And so initially he just says, they're the ones I've entrusted you.
Now she's not told that they are millions, they're already millions.
You know what I mean?
Around the world living in the divine will.
I'm saying millions.
I just mean a large number, okay, because I don't think anybody is count to them.
So I want to form this bond between you and them, okay, so as to have them always around
me, okay.
So there's an example of, I think it's two Corinthians 5, 20.
We are ambassadors for Christ.
We are representing him to others.
You'll know the immediate ones if you're married and you have a family and all the rest of
it.
And he pointed out one in particular to me, Louisa said, I said, Jesus, have you forgotten
about my misery and nothingness in the extreme need I have, what can I do?
And Jesus said, you will do nothing because we have to keep remembering that we entered
the divine will and what we want to do, he actually does it, okay?
You desire it, I do it, do you remember?
Just you've always done nothing, he said to her.
I alone will speak and operate within you and I will speak through your mouth.
And the thing is, he does that with all of us.
Have you ever been spoken to somebody and they asked your advice?
As far as you were concerned, you didn't know the answer to the problem.
But then you find yourself saying something that actually surprises you.
Afterwards they tell you that was exactly what they needed.
Is this the Lord actually using your voice to speak to them?
And it's simply because you're in relationship to him and you're trying to love your neighbor
and so he works through that line of love, okay?
And that's normal, that's ordinary.
That's not extraordinary, saying to you anything.
If only you wanted so, he said, if there's a good disposition in them, I will offer myself
for everything.
In other words, if you really wanted, he said, and if I find a disposition in them to be able
to benefit from this, he said, fine, we're all up and running.
And even if I should keep you asleep in my will, I will wake you up when necessary and
I will let you speak to them.
I will delight more in hearing you speak about my will both in vigil and in sleep.
Now notice and in sleep.
If the Lord wants you sleeping, the sleeping is not sterile.
If the Lord wants you working, the work is not sterile.
But if the Lord wants you sleeping when you're working, then the working is sterile.
And if he has you sleeping when you should be working, then the sleeping is sterile.
The operative thing is his will.
If he wants, now you remember in the early volumes, Louisa had great difficulty when she
was no longer experiencing the passion in all of this and she felt useless and all the
rest of it.
And Jesus told her, look, it's not the suffering.
The suffering only has value if it is my will that you suffer.
But if you suffer and it's not my will, it's like beating an animal out in the field.
There's no value.
Does that make sense?
It's very important just sort of get these points.
So let's come to March the 16th, 1913, "Prayer without fervor."
I have a VIP on this one.
I don't know if any of you know anything about prayer without fervor.
Some of us have a PhD in it.
So Louisa said, "I will write some little things that blessed Jesus told me in the past
few days."
I remember that though, feeling indifferent and cold, I was doing what I usually do.
Now that's the vital bit, that when you're having difficulty in prayer, that you will
continue doing what you normally do, that you won't just stop because it's difficult.
And I thought to myself, who knows how much more glory I gave to our Lord when I felt
the opposite than I feel today.
You see, it's nothing to do with feelings and that's what she's going to be told.
And Jesus said, "My daughter, when the soul prays with fervor, that means you have lots
of feelings."
Now, I want you to put number one on this.
It is incense with smoke.
The smoke are the feelings.
On the other hand, when she prays, feeling cold, but without having allowed anything
extraneous to me to enter, this is number two, it is incense without smoke.
There's nothing of yourself in it.
It is pure gift.
That okay?
Terribly important.
Both of them are pleasing to me, but the incense without smoke pleases me more because
smoke always causes bother to the eyes.
I love that as much.
So then he goes on to give her what I think is a very, very important message.
As I was feeling the same way, she said, "Jesus said, 'My daughter, ice in my will is more
ardent than fire.'"
Now to us, that's a contradiction in terms, isn't it?
What would impress you the most to see that ice has the virtue of burning and destroying
anything that might touch it or to see fire turning things into fire?
Certainly the ice is it.
"My daughter, in my will, things change their nature because to us, ice can't burn."
Okay.
So it's changing its nature.
So ice in my will has the power of destroying anything that is not worthy of my sanctity.
Now that's one of the reasons why the Lord allows us to have dryness in prayer.
So that our motivation is purified and our desires are purified and our prayer is purified
as well.
So ice in my will has the power of destroying anything that is not worthy of my sanctity
and renders the soul pure, clear, and holy.
Now when we get up into the higher volumes, you're going to hear that Louisa has become
like crystal.
That means the light of God can come through, no problem.
Now at an earlier stage, we are opaque.
That means the light can't get through.
So the Lord has to keep purifying, purifying until the light can get through.
So ice in my will has the power of destroying anything that is not worthy of my sanctity
and renders the soul pure, clear, and holy according to my liking, not according to her
liking.
Now who's the more important of the two?
It's him.
This is the blindness of creatures and also of those who are said to be good in feeling
cold, miserable, weak and oppressed and so on.
And the more they feel so-called bad, I love that word bad here because it explains the
numerous times that Louisa has said to the Lord, but I feel so bad.
At our stage of history, we mightn't use the word bad when we'd say all kinds of things.
I got out of the wrong side of the bed today.
Nothing's working right today, you know, things are miserable and blah, blah, blah.
We have all kinds of way of saying it, but she used the simple word bad.
But now you have the explanation of it here.
And the more they feel bad, that is called miserable, weak and oppressed.
The more they huddle within their will, now you see the mistake we make?
We fall back to ourselves, weaving their own maze with which to wrap themselves even more
within their evils instead of making a jump into my will.
In other words, getting out of the junk and going straight into the divine will, regardless
of how you feel.
It's not absolutely brilliant.
In which they would find the coldness fire, the misery, wealth, the weakness, strength,
the oppression, joy, look at the transformation, isn't it absolutely incredible?
So put an envy about two feet tall beside that.
That's something you really, really need to take notice of.
And so what he's saying is don't measure your prayer by your feelings.
It's not because you're fervent that the prayer has value.
The prayer has value if it is done in the will of God with love, with humility, as is value.
So look at this, Jesus said, "I make them feel so bad on purpose in order to give them
in my will, the opposite of the evils they have."
How is that?
Will you put another envy beside that?
And the next time you want to say you feel so bad, you say, "Oh, the Lord has allowed
this to happen because he wants to give me the opposite."
And you jump into the opposite, isn't that okay?
But creatures not wanting to understand this once and for all render vain my designs upon
them.
"This is blindness, this is blindness," he said.
Amazing, isn't it?
Another time Jesus said, "My daughter, take a look at how one who does my will nourishes
herself."
Now, the heading I have for this is feeding on light, feeding on light, operating in the
divine will and power, literally we feed on light.
Okay.
This is a very important message.
At that moment, I saw a sun spreading innumerable rays.
It was so very bright that our sun seemed to be just a shadow.
And a few souls immersed in this light, sucking with their mouths from these rays as if they
were breasts.
Now, those few souls are people in the divine will, few by comparison with the sheer numbers
on the earth.
These souls were estranged from anything else, they detached themselves from everything that
they should be detached from, as if they were doing nothing.
So there's brother and sister nothing.
But while it seemed that they were doing nothing from them came the whole of the divine operating.
Okay?
So he added, "Have you seen the happiness of the ones who do my will?
And how from them only comes the repetition of my works."
Now the repetition of my works, that should be John 14, and I think it's seven.
My disciples will do the same works as I do when I go to the Father.
So it's from these ones in the divine will, comes the repetition of my works.
One who does my will, that means lives in the divine will, nourishes herself with light.
Now God is light, one, John, one, five.
God is light.
So we're nourishing ourselves with God, that is with me, Jesus said.
And while she does nothing, she actually does everything, because we're allowing him to
do it in us.
So she can be certain that whatever she thinks, does and says is the effect of the food which
she takes, that is everything is the fruit of my will.
Now that's the position we need to be on a daily basis.
And for that I want to give you two Corinthians 6, 10.
Because having nothing we have everything, two Corinthians 6, 10.
Now March the 21st, I have hold on a second, 45.
So March the 21st, 1913, the heading is the abandonment of the soul in the divine will
is opium for Jesus, so it gives him a bit of relief.
So continuing in my usual state, I was telling sweet Jesus to condescend to let me share in
his pains, and he told me, my daughter, the opium of the soul is my will.
My opium, that should be a capital M, is the will of the soul abandoned in my will united
to pure love.
Now notice I keep on saying that the summary of the 36 volumes is divine will and love.
This opium the soul gives to me has the power of making the thorns lose in me their capacity
to prick, the nails to pierce, the wounds to cause pain.
It soothes everything for me and puts everything to sleep.
So if you've given me opium, how can you want me to let you share my pains, you said?
If I do not have them from myself, neither can I give them to you, because you can only
give what you have.
Now what Jesus is saying is that living in the divine will is what gives him the comfort
he needs, because it's somebody on earth actually benefiting completely from both the creation
and redemption and sanctification that was God's plan for us.
That's why we comfort him.
And Louisa said, I had Jesus, how good you are coming up with this, it's his first time
to say it to her by the way.
It seems that you want to make fun of me coming up with these terms so as not to make me content.
Okay, now watch this, he gives her a very, very important response, no, no, it's true
he said, it really is like this.
I need much opium, he said, and I want you so abandoned in me as to no longer feel yourself
in such a way that I will no longer recognize you as yourself, but I will only recognize
myself in you.
And I will say to you that you are my soul, my flesh, my bones, in other words, another
little incarnation.
So what he's saying to her is, abandonment in the divine will is better than any suffering.
Suffering has its own function, but abandonment in the divine will is better than anything
else.
So you need to put that as a little heading for the paragraph.
And if we abandon ourselves to the divine will, you'll no longer either concentrate on
yourself or even feel yourself because you're reaching out altogether in such a way that
I no longer recognize you as yourself, but I only recognize myself in you.
So this allows Jesus to bileocate himself completely in us.
It's wonderful.
It's an incredible thing.
And during these times, he said, I need much of these times are, we're into 1913 and World
War I is 14 to 18, isn't it?
So the times are really bad.
I need much opium because if I wake up, I will pour out deluges of scarches, he said.
In other words, there must be some appeasement of the divine justice.
He disappeared then and he came back after Ohio.
Now, I have a heading over this one and there's one word, it's nothingness.
My daughter, many times it happens to souls what happens in the air because of the stench
that emanates from the earth.
Now that stench is the stench of sin and rebellion against God.
And it's pretty awful at the moment, isn't it?
That emanates from the earth.
The air becomes greasy, isn't that interesting?
And one feels such a thick, heavy, oppressive and nauseating air that winds are necessary
in order to remove that grease from the air.
And then after the air has been purified, the finest breeze blows such that one would
remain with one's mouth open in order to breathe that purified air.
All this happens in souls also.
Many times, watch this, complacency, self-esteem, ego and all that is human, grieze the air
of the soul.
That's the thick stuff that he can't stomach.
And I am forced to center the wind of coldness, the wind of temptation, eridity or slander
so that these winds may remove, so that these winds may remove the grease from the air of
the soul, may purify her and bring her back to her nothingness.
Now you've heard me say over and over again, the only safe place is the nothing.
Is that okay?
Then nothingness opens the door to the all, nothingness is not a negative thing.
It's the place where you find everything, okay?
And just to give you something from the gospel, I just can't remember the reference right
now.
He who humbles himself will be exalted.
Yes.
Okay.
So if you just write down, he who humbles himself.
And they will be exalted.
So the nothingness is not a place of negativity, it's a place of openness to God.
But it means that you put the ego and the self and everything aside to let God come.
So then the nothingness opens the door to the all to God.
And the all makes many fragrant breezes blow such that with her mouth open she swallows
the air and remains all sanctified by it, okay?
So you've actually been given an answer there to problems in prayer.
And the problem is the eridity and the difficulty and the coldness and the lack of interest
and you're switched off or whatever the language that you use.
And the Lord says, switch out of that, jump into the divine will, leave all of that, get
into the divine will, get into your nothingness and you're free.
Now wonderful.
Would that save you a couple of hours counseling?
You can do it in a flash.
And the awful thing is you have to pay the counselor and they wouldn't give you the
answer.
Oh dear.
So March the 24th, 1913, Jesus is the contentment of contentment.
The celestial mother was filled with Jesus through her constant thinking of the passion.
Now we're getting a little clue here, okay?
Louisa said I was feeling a certain discontent because of the privations of Jesus and then
he told me.
My daughter, what are you doing?
I am the contentment of contentment.
Do you remember Jesus giving us the Beatitudes in Matthew's gospel?
Matthew five, okay?
And Beatitude is the way people live in heaven.
And Jesus said, if you have this approach to life, you will experience Beatitude on the
earth.
And I know very few people who take that literally, okay.
And Jesus says that he is happiness and Beatitude for us.
Being in you and feeling discontents, you see, Louisa and Jesus are one now, they're in this
divine union for a long time.
So he can feel her discontents, okay?
I recognize they come from you because they can't come from him.
And therefore I do not recognize myself completely in you because discontents are part of human
nature.
They're not part of the divine.
While it is my will that what is human no longer exists in you and only the divine life.
So Louisa says, now, if you are close to somebody in a family or a close relationship or anything,
you'd know instantly if the other person wasn't in good form, wouldn't you?
They wouldn't have to tell you anything.
You see it in the expression, you see it in the way they walk, they sit or anything.
Well if we can see it and we're outside of the person, try and imagine what it's like
for Jesus if he's living inside of us.
He said, look, I feel it more than you do.
Would you give us a break?
And so he says, jump out of that and get into your Beatitude because that's actually where
you're called.
But we're so used to crawling out of our holes, do you know what I mean?
And having nobody to tell you how to get out of your hole, that it seems sort of unreal
in the sense that you can snap out of it, but try it, you'll be amazed.
So Louisa added that she was thinking about Blessed Mother and Jesus said, my daughter,
the thought of my passion never escaped my dear mother.
And by dint of repeating it, because that's what we do in the hours of the passion, isn't
it?
She filled all of herself with me completely, now the word completely is the operative word,
because we can fill ourselves with the Lord, but the completely isn't there, is it?
The same happens to the soul, by dint of repeating, that's in the hours of the passion, what
I suffered, she arrives at filling herself with me.
So there he's saying that by doing the hours of the passion reverently and prayerfully
in the divine will, that we are making great progress, okay?
So April the 2nd, 1913, the soul who does the will of God is the breath of Jesus.
Louisa said I was all afflicted because of the privations of my sweet Jesus.
When Jesus came from behind my shoulders, he placed his hand on my mouth, moved the
bed sheets away from me, which were so close as to prevent me from breathing freely.
Now notice she wasn't completely, you know, she goes into this stiff thing in prayer,
so she obviously wasn't free enough to do it herself, and he moved the bed clothes away
from her.
Just like you would do for your husband or your wife, having a difficulty, you just do
it.
So Jesus did it.
And he said my daughter, one who does my will is my breath.
Now Genesis 2, 7, the breath of God was breathed into man, and man became a living being.
You have John 2023, Jesus breathed it upon the apostles after the resurrection, and they
became a living church before that they hadn't, they just hadn't got it, what Jesus was trying
to do with them.
Now the other thing I want to say, if you look at me for a minute, the sacred name which
the Jewish people will not pronounce is YAH, what does that mean?
My breath, the YAH is the out breath, and the way is the in breath.
And the understanding of the people of the Bible was that the human race is breathing
in the breath of God in birth and breathing back the breath of God in death.
And this cycle is going on on a daily basis.
Hence, for another one of the hundred reasons, abortion is such a heinous thing, preventing
the breath of God to come on the earth.
So Jesus said, one who lives into the divine will is my breath.
And since my breath contains all the breaths of everybody, okay, I administer breath to
all from within the soul who does my will.
And this is why I moved the bed sheets away, I too felt breathing hampered, I think that's
lovely.
That there's you've got an illustration of the closeness of this union, what she feels,
he feels.
And what she has to learn is to feel what he feels.
It's harder on our side, it's easier on his side, okay.
So since we allow the breath of God to breathe in us, he says he can breathe out on others
because of us.
And that means that whether you are aware of it or not, the Lord is affecting people
all around you.
You might only sit beside them at Mass or meet them in the shop or walking down the
street or whatever, he can reach out to them through you and he doesn't, he doesn't make
a fuss about it, he just does it.
Louisa said, Jesus what he is saying, rather I feel that you have left me and you've forgotten
everything and the many promises and so on.
Now what, this time she gets a reaction.
He says, my daughter don't say this to me, for you offend me and you force me to make
you really know what it means for me to leave.
This time she got a real smack, didn't she?
Yeah.
Now because she's been going on and on about it, you know what I mean?
And this time Jesus tells her to cut.
In our normal human relationships, that happens as well, doesn't it?
Because you'll say to somebody, listen, stop, I'm not taking this any longer, I've put up
with this long enough, I'm sure you've said that to somebody at some stage.
Then he added with an ear that was all sweetness, one who does my will, that lives in the divine
will, represents vividly the period of my life upon the earth.
In other words, we are letting Jesus continue his incarnation.
That's why I call us little tiny incarnations, okay.
While on the outside I appeared as man, at the same time I was always the beloved son
of my dear father.
In the same way, the soul who lives in my will has externally the skin of humanity.
I love the expression.
While inside there is my person.
Now the other name for that is a living host, isn't that right?
The skin of humanity and the divine presence.
So that's a living host, so write that on the side, we have this extraordinary thing.
So if the Lord is truly living in me as I become a living host, of course he can affect
everybody around and he doesn't have to tell me.
So externally the person has the skin of humanity while inside there is my person inseparable
– now union means inseparable, okay.
Just like me, in the love and in the will of the most holy trinity, okay.
So the divinity says there is another daughter that we keep upon the earth.
For love of her we sustain the earth because in everything she stands in for us.
So we become one of those people spoken about in Romans 819 that the whole of humanity and
the whole earth is crying out for these sons of God to show themselves, the ones who will
live in the divine will.
So the importance of this presence in us, that Jesus bilocates himself into us and the
two of us are living from one will, that's the inseparability.
So if I shift out of his will, the union is broken, okay.
So April the 10th, 1913, the value and effects of the hours of the passion, okay.
So this is very good to help you to appreciate the hours of the passion.
Jesus said my daughter, one who always thinks about my passion forms a fount within her heart.
One who always thinks about my passion forms a fount within her heart and the more she thinks
about it, the larger this fount becomes, now a fount is a spring, a source, okay.
And just as the waters that spring up, our waters come into everyone, in the same way
this fount of my passion which is formed in her heart serves for the good of the soul,
for my glory and for the good of all souls.
It says creatures here, but I can put souls, okay.
Now for that I want to give you John 7, 37 to 39.
If you come and drink out of your own heart will flow fountains of living water, remember?
So notice the more we do the hours of the passion, the more this fount is built up in
us so that all souls past, present and future are affected.
So this is a very important message.
Louisa said, tell me my good, what will you give as recompense to those who will do the
hours of the passion and the way you taught them to me?
And Jesus said, my daughter, I will look at these hours not as yours but as done by me.
I will give you the same merits as I had as if I were in the act of suffering my passion.
That's number one.
And number two, I'll give you the same effects according to the dispositions of the souls.
This is while they are on the earth, but I could not give them a greater reward.
Then in heaven, this is number three, I will place these souls in front of me, darting
through them with darts of love and of contentment for as many times as they did the hours of
the passion and they will dart through me.
What a sweet enchantment this will be for all the blessed.
So first of all, he gives us his own merits and he gives us the same effects as if we
were actually there with him on the earth.
And then in heaven, it's going to make a big difference as well.
So then he added, my love is fire.
Now from the very beginning of the Bible, they speak of God as fire.
Do you remember the burning bush?
That's Exodus chapter three.
God came to Moses in the burning bush, Exodus three, one to ten.
Do you remember on Pentecost the Holy Spirit came as fire?
Okay.
And in Hebrews, I think it's 10, 29, I'm guessing now, it says, "Our God is a consuming
fire."
Okay.
So my love is fire, he said, "But not the material fire which destroys things and reduces
them to ashes.
My fire, vivifies, makes you more alive and it perfects."
Now, the fire of his love actually does the purification inside of us, an interior purification.
And if it burns and consumes anything, what it burns is all that is not holy, desires,
affections, thoughts which are not good.
So this means that if we are living or trying to live in the divine will, there will be
constant, unremitting interior purification going on.
Because the problem is, we're living ordinary lives.
We're not hidden away in monasteries and we're not hermits by ourselves.
So we're brushing up against people in everyday life and you've got all the stresses and
strains of all of that.
So that affects you, okay?
So this purification goes on all the time.
Now notice the desires, what you want.
The affections, what you love and the thoughts.
Now we've been told many times since volumes one to four that we have to live two Corinthians
10, five.
That means that every thought is captured and given to Christ.
And if you don't know what penance is, try capturing every thought.
So this is the power of my fire, Jesus said, and his fire is love.
To burn evil and to give life to good.
So if the soul feels no tendency to evil, that put an envy beside that.
If the soul feels no tendency to evil within her, she can be certain that my fire is in
her.
That's one, John, three, and I think it's verse five that someone who is truly a union
with God does not sin.
So if the soul feels no tendency to evil within her, she can be certain that my fire
is in her.
But if she feels fire mixed with evil, now evil is worldly stuff and tendencies to rebel.
If they're there, then that mixture tells you that the union isn't there.
It's much to be doubted whether it was my real fire because the divine love purifies
us more than anything else.
And when you go to the hours of the Passion, Jesus explains very well in one of the hours
in Gethsemane that the biggest Passion he had was the Passion of Love.
That is divine love making him pay for everybody.
And then he had the Passion of Sin and then he had the Passion of the Jews.
So made the 9th, 1913, Jesus and his mother are inseparable naturally because both of
them are living in the divine will.
There's only one will between them.
While praying, I was thinking about the moment in which Jesus took leave of his most holy
mother to go and suffer his Passion.
And I said to myself, "How is it possible that Jesus could separate from his dear mother
and she from him?"
I'm amazed at Louisa asking the question after all we've studied, but never mind.
Jesus said, "My daughter, surely there could not be separation between me and my sweet
mother."
Why?
Because they had one will.
Do you remember?
Both of them are living the divine will.
The separation was only apparent, that means it was physical.
She and I were fused together and that's the way we live in the divine will.
That's why the Lord says, "We are inseparable from him because we're fused."
She and I are fused together and the fusion was such and so great that I remained with
her and she came with me.
So it can be said there was a sort of by location, not a sort of.
In other words, the word by location is they're used as an illustration.
And this happens also to souls when they are truly united to me.
And if while praying they let prayer enter into their souls as life, a sort of fusion
and by location occurs, notice a sort of.
I bring them with me wherever I am and I remain in them.
So the more we live in the divine will, the more we are travelling with him because we
are wherever the divine will is.
And he is with us because the divine will is in both of us.
My daughter, you cannot understand well what my beloved mother was for me.
And coming upon the earth I could not be without heaven because heaven was his normal reality.
And my heaven was my mother, why was his heaven his mother?
Because he found the same divine will on earth as he found in heaven.
Okay.
And therefore he found the same love on earth as he found in heaven, therefore he could
tolerate the earth.
There was such electricity running between me and her that not one thought escaped her
which she would not draw from my mind.
And this drawing from me of word will desire action step in some everything formed the
sun, the stars, the moon in this heaven, that is of the Blessed Virgin Mary.
Together with all possible delights that a soul could give me and that she herself can
enjoy.
Oh, how I delighted in the heaven of my mother understood.
Oh how I felt cheered and repaid for everything.
Even the kisses that my mother gave me and closed the kiss of all humanity, returning
to me the kiss of all people.
I felt my sweet mother everywhere.
I felt her in my breath and if it was labored she would relieve it.
I felt her in my heart and if it was embittered she would sweeten it.
I felt her in my step and if it was tired she would give me vigor and rest.
And who can tell you how I felt her in my passion?
At each lash, at each thorn, at each wound, at each drop of my blood I felt her everywhere
carrying out the office of my true mother.
Now you may or may not remember back in Volume 2 that Jesus had asked Louisa to be another
mother for him on the earth and to do the office of mother on the earth, okay.
We'll talk about this in a minute now.
If souls reciprocated me, if they drew everything from me, how many heavens and how many mothers
would I not have on the earth?
So here Jesus is trying to illustrate for us what it means for us to live in Him and
for Him to live in us and what it means to be inseparable and fused, okay.
Because if I am fused 24/7/365 then my will is put aside and only His will is dominating
and because only His will is dominating He's living in me and I'm living in Him, okay.
That's where the inseparability comes and I still have free will, I can still come out
of it but you find as you go on more and more and more your desire to come out of it gets
less and less and less.
So if you've ever really tasted the divine will, what happens is you go deeper and deeper,
there is no other way to go, okay.
And so Jesus was able to explain that when He was separated physically from His blessed
mother during His ministry on earth and during His passion, that the two of them were absolutely
one in what He was doing because there was only one will and that She participated in
everything and this is why the church has always called her the Queen of Martyrs, that
she was crucified spiritually and He was crucified physically, okay.
So this participation is real and the church has acknowledged it from the beginning but
if we would take it on board, it's what He wants to do with each one of us on a lesser
scale because you know all the planets in the sky are not the same size and all the
stars are not the same size, okay.
And all the galaxies are not the same size either, okay.
And notice that He says that with this wonderful communication going on between Himself and
His mother all the time and She entering into all His thoughts, words and actions and everything
else that suns, moons and stars and everything were being formed in that heaven because He's
using the happiness of this relationship He is using the image of heaven and He'll use
it all the time.
And there's something there that I haven't fully grasped at all.
I only know that many years ago I got a priest who was a professor of biology to give a talk
to students that I was involved with because they were all scientists now and there after
a couple of months you know and they weren't going to go to church because after all there
were scientists.
So I said to this priest, look, will you blow them out of the water because it won't take
much blow them out of the water because I know what they don't know, no, I know that
they don't know and I'm in the same boat, but he was absolutely, absolutely brilliant
and he started saying that the structure of the cell in your finger is the same as the
structure of the solar system out there, it's just absolutely brilliant.
And he went through all the sciences and came back to this and he said no, look, since you
didn't even know that, he said, would you for God's sake keep in contact with the one
who made the stars, don't prove yourselves complete fools.
And it was very interesting that at the end of the talk I got an amazing number of paper
airplanes in a sent in my direction.
And some of them were very good targets hitting the head.
Okay, so this union is really fantastic that you're talking about here, but what you need
to do is tease it out yourself on paper, like somebody else really can't give it to you.
So May the 21st, 1913 is also a very important message, how the true consummation is formed.
As I was in my usual state, my beloved Jesus said, my daughter, I want the true consummation
in you that you will truly, genuinely, absolutely give yourself totally without ever stepping
back that you will give yourself completely to allow God to give himself completely to
her.
So that's the true consummation of the spiritual marriage.
Not an imaginary one, in other words, it's saying beautiful things, but it doesn't happen.
But true, though, in a simple and feasible way, number one, suppose that a thought came
to you, which is not for me, you must destroy it.
Now that's your two Corinthians 10, five again.
This is fierce discipline, well it is for me anyway.
You must destroy it and you must substitute it with the divine.
In this way, you will have formed the consummation of the human thought and acquired the life
of the divine thought.
In the same way, if the eye wants to look at something that displeases me or does not
refer to me and the soul mortifies herself, she has consumed the human eye and acquired
the eye of the divine life, well isn't this a wonderful program for Lent, except that you
have to do it all the time, okay.
Oh how I feel these new divine lives, that is the thought given to him and the eyes flowing
in me, taking part in everything I do.
Now I appreciate this a little bit because I find that the dress that I see women wearing
is so immodest that you can't afford to look up, for fear you'd be affected by it.
And so the discipline of the eyes, you know, we were taught this donkeys years ago about
the discipline of the eyes, but now to survive spiritually you need to do it.
And I had a very funny incident recently that I almost bumped into someone because I, right
on top of the person before I actually saw legs, I didn't see the rest of it, but I don't
think they were impressed, but never mind.
So is the thoughts have to be given to him that the eyes must be mortified as well.
He said, and oh how I feel these new divine lives flowing in me, taking part in everything
I do, I love these lives so much that I surrender everything for love of them, notice everything.
Look how generous he is, I surrender everything.
These souls are first before me and if I bless them through them others are blessed, okay.
They are the first to be benefited and loved, and through them others too are benefited
and loved.
Well, in Mark 1038, Jesus was asked a question, who's the first in the kingdom of heaven?
No, you've got the answer.
The people who will pay this price, okay.
So June the 12th, 1913, the effects of fusing oneself in Jesus, very important, okay.
So we've got a lot of very important messages tonight.
While praying, I was uniting my mind to the mind of Jesus, now this follows directly from
all we've just been reading, I was fusing my eyes to those of Jesus and so with all the
rest.
With the intention, because the intention is very important, we've had many messages
about the importance of the intention, of doing what Jesus did with his mind and with
his eyes, with his mouth, with his heart and so forth.
So she obviously fused herself in the mind, the eyes, the mouth, the heart, you know, the
limbs of Jesus.
And as it seems that the mind of Jesus, his eyes, et cetera, diffused for the good of all,
it seemed that I too would diffuse for the good of all uniting and identifying myself
with Jesus.
That's a very simple way of doing it.
Now I thought to myself, what kind of a meditation is this?
What prayer?
I am no longer good at anything.
I'm not even capable of reflecting on something, but while I was thinking of this, Jesus told
me, my daughter, what?
You are afflicting yourself with this.
Instead of afflicting yourself, you should rejoice, because when you used to meditate
and many beautiful reflections used to arise in your mind, you would do nothing but take
from me, bring this part of my qualities and of my virtues.
But now, since the only thing left to you is being able to unite yourself and identify
yourself with me, you take the whole of me.
Good at nothing as you are, that's John 15, 5, without me, you can do nothing.
With me, you are good at everything.
As Philippians 4, 13, I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength.
With me, you are good at everything, because with me, you want the good of all.
And the mere desiring and wanting good produces a strength in the soul which makes her grow
and settles her in the divine life.
Now notice the mere wanting it, desiring it and wanting it, because that's the little
thing you've got in Tony's thing.
If you desire it, I'll do it.
Then by uniting with me and identifying with me, she unites with my mind, producing many
lives of holy thoughts in the minds of creatures.
As she unites with my eyes, she produces many lives of holy gazes in creatures.
Now that's language we don't use, lives of gazes.
And it means that if we fuse ourselves into the mind of Jesus, that he will give the grace
for other people to be able to come into holy thoughts and for other people when we fuse
in the eyes to come into holy gazes as well.
And in this text, it's called lives of thoughts and gazes.
She unites to my heart, to my desires, to my hands, to my steps, to my very heartbeat.
She will give a life, that's a divine life, to desires, actions and steps, but holy lives
because I contain the creative power within me and therefore together with me the soul
creates and does whatever I do.
Now this is a way in which we can influence the human race hugely without ever lifting
a finger, without shifting off your chair.
All you've got to do is fuse into the various parts of Jesus and let him give these lives
of grace at all these different levels to people, all over the world at all time.
It's just amazing.
And that's why he keeps saying that someone living in the divine will appears to be doing
nothing and is in fact doing everything.
But see, people around you will think you're doing nothing as well because you just sit
in there to not to be.
And we live in a society where if you're not doing something, you're wasting your time.
And so people may even accuse you of wasting your time, which is fine.
I remember somebody saying to me at one stage, "What do you do all day?"
and I said, "When I find out, I'll tell you."
She didn't know about the nothing that's, you know what I mean.
And it's this doing thing, because society out there, if you're not active, they don't
understand that you're not externally active.
So Jesus said, "This union with me, part to part, mind to mind, heart to heart, produces
in you, look at this now, in the highest degree, the life of my will and of my love."
And the summary of the 36 volumes is divine will and love.
So he says, "By fusing yourself into Jesus with every part of him, this brings the growth
that you're actually looking for."
So will you put an amazing envy over this entire passage, will you?
And please go over line by line afterwards to make sure that you catch it, okay?
So it produces in you, in the highest degree, the life of my will and of my love.
In this will, the Father is formed.
And in this love, the Holy Spirit is formed.
And through the operating, the words, the works, the thoughts and everything else that
can come from this will and from this love, the Son is formed and here is the Blessed
Trinity formed in souls.
Isn't that something else?
So if we need to operate, it is indifferent to whether, if we know to the capital W, blessed
Trinity, if we need to operate, it is indifferent whether we operate in the Trinity in heaven
or in the Trinity within souls on earth.
Now a person who introduced this whole thing to the church was, I don't know whether she's
St. Elizabeth of the Trinity now or blessed Elizabeth, do you think she's St. Elizabeth?
Yeah, she's Carmelite and her whole spirituality was living with the Trinity.
And she used to say to people, "I'm already in heaven because if you're living with the
Blessed Trinity, you're already in heaven," as would Jesus keep telling us in these divine
will messages that were living the life of the beatified on earth.
So this is why I keep taking everything else away from you because what is to happen in
you is so great.
Be they even good and holy things to be able to give you the best and the holiest, which
is myself, we would say, that text says, "It is I," okay.
In other words, heaven's highest and heaven's best is what's being offered to us.
And I want to be able to make you another Christ as much as it is possible for a creature.
I believe you won't lament anymore, will you?
Now one of the things we do know about life is that life offers you good, better, and best.
And when people reach the good, they get very attached to it.
And when you offer them the better, they're now willing to let the good go for the better.
If they do manage with great struggle and everything to reach the better, then they're
better than the good.
And if you offer them the best, they can say absolutely no.
It's a terrifying mystery.
It really is a terrifying mystery.
And what the Lord is offering us here in the divine will is the best.
But there are people out there living the better.
They're actually living decent spiritual lives, and so they don't feel the need to go for
anything more, but it's sad in a way, but that's the way we are.
I want to give you Sam 82 verse 6, that God says you are sons of God, Sam 82 verse 6.
I said you are sons, sorry, I said you are gods, all of you sons of the most high.
So that's another Christ.
So Louisa said, Jesus, I feel rather that I have become awful bad.
She's back to the feelings again.
And the worst is that I'm unable to find this badness in me, for at least I would do something
to cast it away.
Now Jesus has told her endlessly that there's no badness there, otherwise she wouldn't be
in this relationship, okay?
So that's 1 John 3, 2, that if you really are living in union with God, you don't sin.
Jesus said enough, enough.
You want to go too far into this thought of yourself.
You see the way, each time she does this, she's going back to herself, and he said no, no,
no, stop reflecting on yourself.
Think of me, he said, and I will take care of your badness as well, and go to leave it
there for tonight.